Hey say you will get where you are and
then just fine
again
no connection connection connection
it's a consciousness jump boom oh you
might reject but you'll have to stick
again so you still have it so you can
still go hmm versus hey B oh yeah see
okay it's just my moving body moving he
goes you still up okay right and you
will show that you have
Oh
he comes in he comes out say one both he
comes in boom he comes up comes in this
one I think I
they the cuts not the point
it's a my point to keep the feeling you
see keep the feeling he goes he's going
if you're not sure what the difference
is it's a matter of balance it's a
matter of balance
like last night
boom touch out and your prescription
he's going to try to get up is to not
let me get contact
and then option a don't let him get up
take now on the lipid drop what is their
place on the midline where you can draw
and the deck to see okay
don't take that draw
so are you couple of your deep pot
weapon hammer editors if I tend to take
this one okay I don't come around and
my support site maybe you are more for
days than me but I hang up one two three
secondly don't touch the white
controllably
and don't draw the weapon touch the
weapon secure your grip draw the line
text 11 not close find that fumble or
find the guard and secure to that we
don't want to draw with these they fall
out even if you're using them okay
so touch the weapon draw the book touch
the weapon
lightgrip same same IV touch same I can
touch say my content boom boom okay so I
keep my mind
I am NOT holding it it's the same
relationship that he was thrown with so
if I'm free now vignette boom
here there's there's no pit it's just
kinda good let's just can you lift
your arm yeah he can
when he starts to get up
I used the adhesion to take it back out
not he sucks it out when I shove it down
nor was i holding it down so you can't
but as she gets up I take the new
position which is in the prescription
going to be further out there he goes
and I got it so don't go in here whoa
either if you that's where you got stuff
it's the same thing can you and as he
gets up don't shove it back down and he
gets up bring a buck
so energy stuffing in hitting a mosque
I either you may need it and then
rebound it off of the mouth and this is
not a separate hand there I believe
about enough that we're stuck we're
stuck
okay just enough so if the guy is really
close
like why should I use separating bow you
come here
he got really close no no no with that
okay Jimmy got really loose Mohawk
reject out
they relate to each other in getting
always it's the same doubt okay so don't
make them popular well now this is not
the time for this in the same way
boom he comes up that's not the time for
that you see how over time okay
I did the opposite to hold that so pay
attention to the mine
so he passed the arm
k to the passing half-naked arm you see
there the arm in Nigeria adhesion
okay there's still some agency to your
strategy you don't know I do I may be
but now you have to be able to employ it
tactically okay so I'm seeing a lot of
weird stuff what are the guys on my team
here
Wow then you're done okay or I've seen a
lot the guys out there and you're trying
to keep them out more okay this is not
right you're overextended okay
also if you don't stop the external
stuff so if he comes up and I go like
that yeah I will never learn it
okay I'm trying to get you to Disneyland
and you keep going dogs very farm to
Disneyland it's better that you don't
get to Knott's Berry Farm you get it
they think then you get to us very far
more nothing to it so you're not gonna
get to Disneyland don't go to Knott's
Berry Farm
okay so boom boom and here you see here
because you might be here and you might
have thought ultimate power right but
this is not true there's a finite see
you into that you get it so when I'm
when I'm pushing here then this kind of
overt external way it's might be strong
enough it might be strong enough
okay put it humbly monkey right so it's
not that hard
[Music]
sit down right so that's how we're doing
and I don't need to do it if I have a
knife I just have to keep them off
balance okay let's try this this was not
we're not doing that he just come in on
there
so
[Music]
you are prescribed as 110 as you keep
trying to win the Nagas duty you wasting
50% and now you can't reject holy a 13
year old boy you are go it's
unacceptable
though if you were just do what we say
look project with the knife in the
projection wool very common wool all on
the side
but oh maybe you use the tomboy if you
taking Monica you use the pommel bottle
it's gonna hurt okay but what I'm not
doing is something counter we have one
who sings okay I'm not stopping him
I'm keeping a little possible totally
lose their intention is good dead
okay you see stuff here
here we go
go get trapped on the harm chasing the
arm full bowl you'll feel it will feel
the disconnection if you feel the
opening don't let them get here hey whoa
you gotta felt it kid we'll do that all
day go boom okay
okay now let's try it again okay so you
can do whatever and get up us it's gonna
be up to our big game because you've
been using this and they're gonna just
do whatever so you can do whatever do
whatever do goofy stuff okay
it does not it doesn't matter okay
he reaches it doesn't matter we see
where we touch the stick okay if I if I
don't have a life out of time what I
gonna do I can do the easy one go
[Music]
no but I will be if I put in here
why go here because I'm going to get a
knife retention issue okay so violence
won't be thanks for the love gun boom
got it don't stick it in places where
you're okay no the knife is like this I
won't okay
don't hold it out like that go
that's why you carry one nice and shy
beside if you look at the nature of this
weapon even when you stick it and the
guy rolls so just like you did last you
come up right rubbish and you drop
something else seamless okay so don't
freak out if that happens this is an
unoffending drill right so the only
problem was weed out just like this
would be a problem so this start being
more more alive than our movie star
now now I'm gonna go call I'm moving I
don't do the drill what was wrong with
the drill I've been stuck there okay
whenever gee one of the joys
I don't know my movie is there don't
give yourself a weapon retention just
like if you want body art would be
wrestling with them you get it so when
you go to the night you're not going out
here your art is a fine art navigates
are a higher
okay what did i do different I was here
wasn't I
well what got you different yes and you
jump so you're going to get in a fight
over the knife
here then okay he goes watch what I do
how about not move yeah you got it
always for the music change position
now do not check we're you see so when
you hear oh not now and look you see you
see so if we're duty was up and he was
dead here in Monaco then when I'm
talking to your dad you see and same
thing if that goes dead that hand comes
it oh it's not dead now it's not that
you understand
so what you're doing is getting the
drill right okay go in my bed you don't
have hands I can correct you see I come
[Music]
yes I'm afraid I'm looking for that you
see
so why what am i okay I'm not gonna
doing here and then she tucked out okay
I got to go do it again
you got it so is this
[Music]
okay okay now you look at sting you see
and now you got two more
don't cover what you want to cut okay go
out the back go out the back there you
go get up and out lots of work left to
do right